what's going on guys my name is David
Tomic and welcome back to the channel
today we're not going to be doing your
typical boring unboxing video instead
we're gonna dive straight into the a
user review of the Microsoft Surface
laptop - I've had this product for about
seven months now
and I can buy five say that it is the
best laptop I've owned however stick
around to the end of the video and
you're gonna find out why I'm gonna tell
you not to buy it yet so straight out of
the box you're gonna notice that the
surface laptop 2 comes in a very sleek
profile design it has that wedge finish
very similar to the Apple MacBook Air if
you compare the weight of this versus a
MacBook Air you're actually going to
find out that this one is a little bit
lighter by about 50 grams give or take a
few now that's quite impressive
considering the fact that Apple has been
the leaders in light thin powerful
laptops for almost a decade now
whereas Microsoft has just come into the
game and they're absolutely killing it
with this product sticking to the
externals of this laptop on the side
you're going to notice that it has a
proprietary Microsoft charging point
this is actually one of my key
disappointing features of this laptop it
does not have USB C at the moment if I
had USB C it would be a lot more
future-proof in my opinion however all
that were left with really is one single
USB port on the side and thunderbolt
port as well we also do have a headphone
jack which is fantastic they haven't
gone ahead and removed it like every
other company started with their mobile
phones but we are left with only one USB
I guess this note is a little bit unique
to me and not many people have actually
done this to their service laptops to
geez yeah but within the first couple of
weeks of owning this one I've
accidentally dropped it straight on to
the concrete so the corner here I'm not
sure if you guys gonna be able to tell
on this lens but it has dented the
tiniest bit
however the screen did not shatter I've
had service products in the past where
I've accidentally dropped them or
knocked them and the screen has
absolutely shattered into a million
pieces
thankfully hand on heart this one did
not break and it was fantastic news for
me because the screen replacements are
about a thousand dollars and that's not
something you want to pay when you've
already spent three thousand dollars one
laptop moving forward after you've set
up this laptop and you're using it on a
day-to-day basis you're actually going
to be pleasantly surprised by the fast
load time it incorporates the brand new
windows face recognition software and
unlike any other computer I've used in
the past including other surface devices
it's actually lightning fast now this is
something that's gonna please you
diehard gamers out there the keyboard on
this product is actually incredible for
something with a very sleek modern
design it actually has quite a lot of
trouble in the keys you're going to
notice that you can hear the keys typing
away something that a lot of people have
been complaining about this product here
on the internet on YouTube in particular
is actually the screen brightness how
about I haven't had any issues with this
product I've used that all around the
world in different lighting situations
in bright lights like in the studio and
even outside in direct sunlight I
haven't had an issue to date unlike in
the past where I've owned the generic
surfaces themselves with the little
flippy flimsy keyboard their screens are
actually incredibly hard to deal with in
the harsh sunlight conditions there was
one day where I was sitting next to my
partner on my surface and she had her
macbook out and it was night and day she
could see everything perfectly clear and
I was really struggling to see my
content on the computer okay so this is
a feature which may or may not interest
you personally to me it made absolutely
no difference what the speakers sound
like on this machine however if you're a
video editor in 2019 chances are you
might want the speakers to be crisp and
clear when you don't have your
headphones laying around and you're
doing some video editing on the fly now
pulled up one of my own videos here and
set the volume for about 50% I'm maybe a
meter a meter and half away from the
camera and I'm gonna hold it from this
distance and again closer to the camera
so you guys can get a clearer
understanding of what the speakers are
like how powerful they are and how clear
they are what's going on guys
my name's Emmett Amish and welcome back
to the channel today and they have it
the speakers in this device actually
quite good from a little small device
that weighs less than a MacBook Air it
is actually incredible what they've been
able to produce the sound does kind of
seem to come through the keys as there
isn't too many open holes and ports on
the device but that isn't a deal-breaker
at all one thought that I had found this
laptop and with actually most new
products on the market is the fact that
gets very hot very quickly especially
when running programs like Premiere Pro
or Photoshop or even After Effects one
thing that did surprise me is it gets
very hot and very loud when casting over
your chromecast so when you're streaming
a movie on YouTube onto your TV for some
reason the computer can't really handle
it the programs don't talk well to each
other and the fan just kicks on to
maximum straightaway I did a test the
other day and stream for 40 minute video
from my laptop so microcast in the
living room and the battery dropped from
a hundred percent down to 76 percent
that's 24 percent in 40 minutes now
considering this laptop is meant to have
a 14 and a half hour battery time 24
percent in 40 minutes
is very disappointing however on a
general day-to-day basis I did get about
6 or 7 hours out of this laptop without
having to worry about charging it
throughout the day
I have never to this day got 14 and a
half hours and I'd be impressed if you
could get 14 and a half hours especially
considering it says with genuine video
content viewing something that is a bit
of a nice touch and something that was a
little bit worried about when purchasing
this laptop was it a Patera keyboard the
keyboard is a nice soft suede kind of
finish and it's really nice to type on
on a day to day basis I always thought
that the general sweat marks and heats
of your hand would leave stains on this
keyboard
however with 7 months of using this
product there isn't a single mark on it
and it is a fantastic sign for me so
what's the verdict should you go out and
buy this laptop hand down straight away
throw all your money away should you
wait a couple months or should you
completely avoid it well I've been doing
my research and as always Microsoft
tends to release new products later on
in the year we are expecting to see a
brand new
surface laptop product late 2019
somewhere in the october/november period
now if you're not desperate for a new
laptop I would personally recommend
waiting because chances are this new
laptop is going to come out with a USB C
port and like I said USB C is the future
so this laptop would be a lot more
future proof whereas this one here at
the surface laptop 2 will become
obsolete in three four years when
everything's moved to USB C if you are
in the market for a brand new laptop
today then hands down I would recommend
the surface laptop to it has been a
great device for general day-to-day work
and even video production and movie
editing and running three companies
simultaneously it is however at the top
of the range surface laptop - and I
don't have any experience with a lower
end of the product range however I do
believe that all of them will be quite
good and you shouldn't have too many
problems regardless of the model that
you select and they have it guys that's
my personal opinion
on my seven-month-old day to day run and
gun laptop if you liked this video make
sure you smash that subscribe button
20:19 style give it a like maybe drop a
comment and let me know your thoughts
and like always I'll see you next Monday